[Music]
[Music]
welcome to stick to football the live
version if you join us in the BRM
welcome and if you're listening in
podcast version hi we're gonna have some
fun today we get to grade the AFC West
draft classes 30 minutes of mellow
gushing about why no one can stop the
Kansas City Chiefs I hope y'all are
ready the rest this division also did
pretty well if you missed the news all
on Monday you get today and you get
tomorrow that stick to football it's
going on vacation we are already
planning virtual vacations Matt Melo and
Connor Rogers we are excited hopefully
you guys are as well today is going to
be fun you guys leave your draft on
draft questions right here in the
comments below or you can even tweet
them at us just use that hashtag if
you're old
that's the pound sign on your phone and
then draft on draft ah I was right
confuse what they meant by hashtag
thanks for playing on sign there it is
alright let's get right into these
grades I'm excited today
mellow let's just get all this out of
the way off the top you can gloat
your team won the Super Bowl Yatta Yatta
Yatta you've been a fan for to you last
chance to read about the kids of City
Chiefs for a while so buckle up folks
cuz I'm gonna do it today not really I
actually didn't like their draft I'm
going to give this thing an F because I
don't see the needs in a running back
this your joke for the Kansas City
Chiefs do I like the fit and Clyde
Edwards Hilaire yep I sure do but I
don't think it was a position of need I
think that this team can win a Super
Bowl with anybody on roster at running
back including myself and they took the
5th best one that I had in this class
he's gonna be great he's gonna be a
Provo where I've said it on this show
before but I don't like the draft in
what they did with Clyde over to layer I
had to brace myself for them taking a
running back it's going to work out it's
going to look great but any running back
would have looked great here you also
could have taken a corner corner is a
huge need defense is a huge need so I
said I'm gonna give this great at F I'm
actually gonna change it to a seat for
corner because you could have taken a
corner in the first round and also a C
for Championships because it doesn't
matter who the Chiefs draft they are
still going to be the champions and
probably run it back and win another
Super Bowl I'm so convinced to have what
your actual greatest
that's what makes this so tough we could
sit here and absolutely kill this trap
and it doesn't mean we don't think that
the Chiefs are gonna be you know not in
the Super Bowl this year or anything
like that so I'm actually with you here
Melo I give this a c-minus so I was a
little more harsh on it Claud Edwards
elaire he's gonna be a really good
player for Andy Reid did they need to
take a first round running back
especially somebody that is not Dion
Gerry Swift I don't think so so I
thought this was a team that desperately
needed help at the cornerback spot there
were plenty of them on the board not
just in the first round but also in the
second round when they took Willie gay
now Willie Jay has a ton of athleticism
of course that's really really exciting
but the problem was guys he was an
average college linebacker sure you can
google the combine numbers the
athleticism it's a leap there's no doubt
about that but he was just an average
player in college so do I think he
brings more speed sideline to sideline
range and hopefully some coverage
ability to the Chiefs front seven he
does but is this enough for this defense
this year I don't believe so that's my
problem they didn't do enough for the
defense is Chris Jones gonna show up on
that franchise tag number this year even
if he does even with honey badger and
hopefully one Thornhill getting fully
healthy I don't like what they have at
cornerback they had two shots to address
that they chose not to so the Chiefs are
gonna be really really good this year
but I don't like what they did in the
draft yeah guys I'm right there with you
I don't actually know what grade Melo
gave but I gave them a C as well no
corner was huge for me
even with bashad breeland's legal
troubles coming after the draft I don't
think you could roll in I liked your
various Ward a lot I do not think that
Rashad fitting is gonna be a top really
a top to starter at the corner spot for
the Kansas City Chiefs oh I feel like
they got a little bit cute I love Clyde
the glide here's my I believe my number
two back in this class when it was all
said and done I liked him I did not
think they needed to draft him at 32
overall when as you guys said Jake
Dobbins if he had been there and around
2 is not that different and I think that
is one of the concerns was okay where is
the run on the running back position
going to happen because you want to make
sure you get one before you draft again
at 63 but I still think like either of
you take exact moss-like you're still
getting a big upgrade or Darington evans
like there were other guys you could
have taken
instead of quiet and I do a love Clyde
if you're a fantasy football player you
are taking him very early and he's going
to catch 50 or 60 passes in this offense
it's gonna be fantastic but I still
think it was a little bit cute let's
talk about Lucas nying they need a young
offensive lineman Martinez Rankin we'll
see when he's gonna be able to play and
one of those guard spots but Eric Fisher
getting older Mitchell Schwartz getting
older it's not time yet to cut bait on
these guys so I did like the move to get
a kind of a developmental offensive
lineman in the third round someone who
is coming off a hip injury I think
that's why he fell in the draft player
didn't give up a sack the last three
years in college
Lucas Knight has some ability I do
wonder where they're gonna transition
him is he a guard easy a tackle where
are we gonna see him play at the next
level guys but this was honestly
thinking like the biggest need they
checked off I'm not a believer that
Willie gays can be able to make a huge
splash right away and I'll echo it again
the secondary is a problem but when you
can score 50 who cares who your corners
are maybe it actually doesn't matter
that much they didn't seem to think so
let's go to the Denver Broncos the team
that finished second in this division
last year and I believe has closed the
gap a little bit with the Kansas City
Chiefs Melo Denver maybe has their guy
in Trulock seems like they have some
building blocks on offense you bring in
Melvin Gordon it seems like they're
ready to take that step I think this was
the best draft class in the AFC West and
the Denver Broncos really hit it on the
nail that nail in the head here Jerry
jr. was the number one receiver on my
board and they get him this early false
to him drew lock has just got to be
mouth-watering with the targets he has
the guys like Judy and handler to go
along with what they already had with
Sutton and no a fan at tight in this is
the team that really scares me as a
Kansas City chief fan and then you get
some protection later on I really like
what they did and I think they had a
strategy going into this draft protect
drew lock and give him some targets they
did a very good job with that I'm going
to give them an a-minus
Chiefs fans Chargers fans Raider friends
you all should be nervous about what the
Denver Broncos are doing and what
they're building with drew luck I was a
huge fan of this draft as well I gave it
a flat out a now we're very curious to
see Kendrew lock builds off of an
impressive rookie stretch last year
that's what everyone
wants to see but did they put things
around him weapons and good talent
around him to excel yes they did
absolutely when I look at this trap sure
I love Jerry judy KJ handler very
dynamic speed threat that can work out
of the slot when they have Courtland
Sutton and Judy playing on the outside
Judy can play in the slot as well but
also to fix that I look at here guys
would cushion Barry they needed to find
the center after losing Connor McGovern
they got really good value with cush and
Barry all the way 83 and then even
McTell than the game somebody that was a
former five-star recruit on the
defensive line and just kind of got lost
in a very very poor Arkansas program so
when I look at what the Broncos did this
wasn't a one player draft this wasn't a
hit they got two awesome receivers we're
talking about them so much because of
fantasy football even going all the way
down to Wake Forest linebacker Justin
Stern ad I felt like they got pieces
this could be a five player draft which
is very rare to see in the NFL but I
feel that good about what Denver did
here yeah I like this draft a lot I love
that they maybe have identified the
quarterback of the future I think as a
collective we really believe in Drew
lock taking that next step so instead of
doing what we've seen other teams have
like hey we have a good young
quarterback yeah now he can go figure it
out they said let's give Jerry Judy and
KJ handler to go with Portland Sutton
Noah fan
Melvin Gordon you add Alberto from the
zoo as well like they really built that
cushion for Drew lock my biggest concern
with this entire draft is they did not
address the offensive tackle position
you're gonna go into the 2021 offseason
Guerra bulls is not your long-term
answer left tackle I would have loved to
have seen maybe that round three pick
where they took the corner out of Iowa
maybe you go offensive tackle there
instead so I think next year that's
gonna be a gigantic need for them the
offensive tackle class looks early it's
like it's gonna be pretty strong but you
got to think this is a team that man
they should be all over Jason Peters
who's available as a free agent right
now I think that is a move for them I am
gonna give it an A+ though thought they
had a very very good draft overall and
again you have to give credit to a team
that is willing to go get playmakers for
your young quarterback they did that
with the two receivers early on guys so
we're gonna take just a little bit of a
break then we'll get to the rest of the
division we have to tell you that
today's show is sponsored by State Farm
with the State Farm mobile app for
roadside assistance State Farm is able
to assist you quicker than John Ross at
the combine and unlike John Ross State
Farm won't live out the 40 time wait
okay no wait stapled without languish on
the Bengals I are four years I through
that other part of myself state farms
help us so fast that they were confident
enough to skip the combine and focus on
their product unfortunately due to
recent circumstances and tennis at the
pro day was scarce causing many people
to question the four to two the State
Farm reportedly ran state farms the rare
prospect that is quick and fast
Thank You State Farm for supporting
stick to football I'm gonna take shots
at John Ralston sporty time every chance
we get on this show I don't know that he
comes out he's like actually I ran a 4-3
until he runs it again and front support
to two I'm never going to believe that
that's gonna happen that will be my
great conspiracy theory
don't forget y'all can leave draft draft
questions right here in the comment
stream we're gonna answer a couple of
those at the end of the show if you
missed it sees across-the-board I think
for the the Chiefs Paulo gave a couple
different grades and then A's across the
board for the Denver Broncos so we're in
agreement thus far the Las Vegas Raiders
their stadium looks like a Roomba but
they had a pretty good Draft Connor you
get to go first on this great in
thoughts for those Las Vegas Raiders a
top-notch draft for the Las Vegas
Raiders this wasn't a - for me guys when
you look at what they did we loved Henry
rugs we loved the speed element he
brings yes Damon Arnett was a reach
there's no doubt about that I had him
more in the third round kind of range
instead but they made up for it Lynn
Bowden jr. is gonna play a little
running back a little wide receiver do
it all one of the best yard after catch
guys in the entire draft
Brian Edwards a big bodied possession
player four-year starter in the SEC
that's rare kind of stuff and when you
look at what Lynn Bowden can do on
special teams as well they just infused
this offense with talent around Derek
Carr they've been building the offensive
line for a couple years
we know how special of a player Josh
Jacobs already is Darren Waller at tight
end but now you bring in all of these
weapons the speed of rugs the possession
ability of Edwards Bowden the ability
with the ball in his hands
on day three you go get what I thought
were two starters in guard John Simpson
out of Clemson just a powerhouse typical
typical kind of player for their scheme
in the trenches and a slot corner and a
meek Robertson that I thought was a
second round player you got him a pick
139 I love what mike Mayock and Jon
Gruden did in this draft and even with
the reach on our net that was a little
difficult to explain it felt like they
made up for it in other areas so a nice
a - for Vegas yeah I like this trap - I
actually like every pick that they have
outside of the Arnett deal and I like
our net I don't think he's a bad corner
I think that Mayo just has to learn how
to work that draft board move down and
get the guy that you are targeting I
mean we saw it with Cleveland Farlow we
see it again here with our net learn how
to work that board man because you you
got great picks here no one opens draft
any minute I'm gonna give it a b-plus
because I do like every pick that they
had they looked at that receiver
position and said man we need a lot of
help let's go get rugs and let's get
Brian Edwards I think those two guys
complement each other very well Edwards
was a guy that was hurt and if you were
able to go through this draft process
healthy like everyone else I don't think
he's available there in the draft when
he is I think he's a second-round guy
you can see him here he can separate
he's a big body guy Derek Carr is gonna
love him and when you have Henry rugs
opposite of this guy you've got some
weapons there to work with in Las Vegas
they should have named their stadium the
room booked because these guys are gonna
be cleaning the house oh baby he's also
a great punt returner Brian Edwards this
if you're watching the show you can see
the b-roll he's a fantastic route runner
again just two injuries he had to kind
of freak injuries one of the Senior Bowl
one in training that kelp kept him from
being able to participate I like Brian
Edwards a lot guys I am I'm so torn on
this draft I love Henry rugs what they
did they got a ton of starters as Connor
highlighted they didn't have any pics
around five six and seven I think that
makes their draft even look a little bit
better as well because like all these
are household names even like Tanner
Muse you're getting as Connor said
starter level players in the foot in the
fourth round because they didn't have
those later picks I cannot get over the
Damon Arnett pick though there's a
difference between evaluating and
valuing
and mike Mayock right now it's a good
evaluator he's not good at the valuation
port portion but look at this man
henry rugs the third he's just so
special and what we said it I felt like
four months
on this show of now the Raiders could
have their Tyree kill type wide receiver
and it seems like they're set with
Derrick Carter quarterback like this is
two drafts of row now they haven't made
a move at quarterback they're giving car
those weapons to try and prove himself
to get back to who he was when he was
having kind of an MVP caliber year
before he got hurt several years back so
giving him those weapons I do like that
a lot
I gave it a b-plus the Arnett pick
brings this way down for me I think
otherwise we're talking about the
Raiders he's having one of the best
drafts in the entire 2020 class now how
about the LA Chargers they were
connected to everyone before the draft
and then it was like you know what
whichever quarterback gets past Miami
that's who they're gonna draft that's
what they did
Connor you get to take it away I know
you were not the biggest Justin Herbert
fan I was not I thought he was a second
round player I thought he was a
developmental player had him evaluated
almost identically to how I evaluated
Josh Allen but something I liked more
about Allen was his mindset and demeanor
on and off the field so I thought that
even separated them while I liked
Herbert less the physical talent is
there guys now the mental aspect of the
game processing is something that he
will simply have to get better at you're
gonna see the splash throws here the
ability to throw the ball down the field
some anticipation throws not a ton
really good athleticism I really like
Kenneth Murray you obviously got the
best returner in the draft and Joe Reed
Aloha Aloha Gillman is somebody that can
play special teams but overall this
draft nobody's gonna remember this draft
for Joe Reed and a lo he Gilman guys and
not even Kenneth Murray who I think it's
gonna be a good player they're gonna
remember this draft for what Justin
Herbert becomes if you're the sixth
overall pick in the draft at quarterback
you better be almost a star you need to
really be at least a top 12 quarterback
I have said this for months maybe even a
year now I don't think that's Justin
Herbert ceiling guys I don't I don't
think I'll ever be a top 10 top 12
quarterback so unfortunately the
Chargers they did some good things that
defense gonna be a ton of fun a ton of
to watch I really like Anthony Lynn then
he's actually an underrated coach in the
NFL but this draft because of the
household name they attach to it it was
a C for me and I'm going with a b-plus
here I like what they did outside of
Herbert again I don't like Herbert
either me and Connor pretty much agreed
on that second round guy developmental
maybe he'll get to sit behind tie rod
for a year or two and figure out how to
play this game and how to play the
position really but when you look at a
guy like Kenneth Murray that they traded
back into the first round to get it's
one of my favorite linebackers I've ever
seen that this guy does everything and
now you have Kenneth Murray between the
middle of the field with Derwin James
that is terrifying like that will
literally give running backs and
receivers of nightmares with what this
guy can do he was a tackling machine at
Oklahoma has speed too though there's a
lot of question after a sophomore year
does this guy have speed to get sideline
to sideline he went out and proved it is
junior year I love what they're building
on this defense it's going to be scary I
don't know how you beat the kids at City
Chiefs but I think that the Chargers are
trying to load up on defense to say
let's try our best to slow these guys
down and maybe it works I love the
pieces that they're adding on the
defense well that's where I was gonna
come in I don't think this draft closes
the gap with you in Kansas City we saw
what Denver in Las Vegas did they added
weapons on offense because you're
basically saying we can't stop my homes
let's just try to keep up so let's add
receivers the trucker's didn't do that
they took in my pipe with you guys a
developmental quarterback I was higher
on him than either of you but still
developmental player you did not address
address the left tackle position which
is a gaping hole in a in a conference
and in a division that is so good at the
pass rusher spot Frank Clark is gonna
eat over there max Crosby is gonna eat
over there I mean they're gonna be all
day and on Miller Bradley Chuck right
and your left tackles suck I'm sorry
unless you're gonna sign Jason Peters
here and maybe Larry Warford your
offensive line is not good enough no
matter who's back there at quarterback
so when I look at that I love Kenneth
Murray I like to Joshua with Kelly just
fine Joe reading KJ Hill are a lot of
fun it's kind of smaller really
productive college football receivers
but if you're a Chargers fan and I'm not
sure there are actually any of you but
if you are a Chargers fan out somehow
there's no effing way you're sitting
there today being like you know what
we're being that
after this draft is the one this is
gonna do it we're being the Chiefs no
you're not you're not doing it you're
not even beat the Broncos after this
draft to be fair that's thirty one other
team maybe I gave it a B and as I'm
talking I wish I had given it like a C I
just I don't it like Connor said it's
all about Herbert if he out plays all of
our expectations then maybe this turns
into something I think on his best day
of his entire life
he's like Carson Wentz on the best day
of his life
ever and I Carson Wentz isn't a top ten
quarterback sorry I'm left go so alright
that was my rant Chargers gonna be those
are our grades for the AFC West don't
forget tomorrow NFC West where I get to
rip apart my favorite team the San
Francisco 49ers now you can still leave
draft I'll draft questions we've got a
little bit of time while you're watching
this amazing gridiron heights cut up
leave those questions for us I have in
evidence
I am tractor Seto let me know if you
need to quarterback next year
hello Derrick yeah I think I'll go to
space for a little bit going forward now
that Brady has been defeated the AFC has
returned after a four-year absence I
don't care if he got defeated no I can
take away his six dogs team trip to
Miami bro think of all the bespoke suits
I get to wear I'm sorry I found the
courage to tell a football tryouts
magic this is Mysterio Paulo hey kid I
think it's real cute when you run around
without the threat of Patriots his
dimension the NFC has grown new monsters
every year nerds
kid had no idea I'm just following
Kyle's sister lead just run it we see
you watching the episode just wonder
mention State Farm can I finish it okay
yeah hello I'm Jimmy Garoppolo jimmy
garage I hate a very proud child back
baby
actually our schemes we can make you see
[Music]
kid was a bomb yeah got it whatever so
much pain and so much joy watching those
two square hey let's play a little game
real quick
forget mellow first person to leave
hashtag STF in the comments we're gonna
send some free swag your way first
person hashtag STF in the comments we're
gonna throw some VR gear your way our
producers will take care of it so just
two just a reward our amazing sticky
string and with us here on YouTube and
in the Bleacher Report app free swag I
love it you throw me a free shirt I'm
wearing I probably the next day I do
know that about you alright let's pick
division winners I don't know that we
need to really go into this mellow you
know I think we do because this is a
very competitive inna Kansas City Chiefs
and I can say that after ripping apart
their draft and even
I'm a Chiefs fan I think they are head
and shoulders above everybody else
Denver's making it competitive but
they're not there yet we'll see what
drew Locke can do but for right now it's
the kids the City Chiefs for the
foreseeable future I think it's the
Chiefs as well it'd be hard to pick
against them only because it's very hard
to pick against Pat mahomes and Andy
Reed now do I think things could be a
little bit more competitive this year I
I definitely do I look at their defense
there are some holes there are some
questions is Chris Jones gonna show up
that's a big question for me right now
but I will not pick against Pat mahomes
yeah that's probably gonna - yeah you
just don't pick against patty after what
he's done for two years I'll pick the
Chiefs as well all right let's get into
some draft on draft questions don't
forget that tomorrow NFC West break down
right here 5:00 p.m. Eastern Time
first question though from taking the
high road if you were a GM in the AFC
West
what would your bigger priority be
stacking up on defense on defensive
studs or powering up your offense to
keep up with Kansas City so do you want
to go the Denver model the Vegas model
or whatever the hell the Chargers did
Connor you want to take this one first
you got off yeah I'd love to I mean I
think we've gotten to see both of it
which is exciting I personally would go
the model that the Raiders and Broncos
clearly outlined they went to the draft
and said hey we need playmakers across
the board and that doesn't mean we need
a number one wide receiver that doesn't
mean we need a number two wide receiver
that means we need three wide receivers
that are fully capable starters with
differing skill sets when you look at
the Raiders they have an elite speedster
and Henry runs when you look at the
Broncos they have an elite speedster in
KJ handler obviously teams have
possession guys Brian Edwards Portland
Sutton is just an absolute freak Jerry
Judy Lynn Bowden they're just anything I
talked about the tight end running back
situation I already they're loaded at
all of those spots absolutely loaded
they're gonna go into it and say hey
we're gonna try to outscore the Chiefs
that's what I would do the Chargers side
was clearly hey we need the most speed
we can possibly have on defense to match
up with these guys you saw as they moved
up for Kenneth Murray you've seen it
with their free agency you've seen it
with their drafts over the years so when
I look at it
I would go offense for offense
I think it's a bold strategy and I have
the perfect plan on how to beat the
Kansas City Chiefs I'm just not gonna
share it with anybody my personal use
only no I think I would go offense as
well because not only all right do you
want to try to outs like you want to
keep pace with that Chiefs offense
the Chiefs defense is not that good I
mean it knows I know how take but like a
linebacker a corner not that good so I
really have no offensive weapons did no
corners at all I like ward I like word
well enough let's keep her out there in
it again they don't have the cordis yeah
bulletin board material Mike team has a
one corner as well I can't really talk
any trash here but I would go that so
you're not only adding to try to score
but you're attacking their weakness on
defense so I think that is a smart way
to build a team I would actually do here
is I would disagree with both of you
guys I load up on defense I would do
exactly what the Tennessee Titans are
doing I would load up on two running
backs one hell of an offensive line in a
great defense and say moams can't beat
us if he's sitting on the sidelines and
then you pray that he dislocates a
kneecap or throws an interception when
he's doing his no-look pass I really
think that's the only way you have a
chance to beat these guys control the
clock go back to 1980 s football and
just run the ball down that defensive
throat I think the 49er started to do it
the Titans have had success doing it I
hate to put that out there but I think
that's the only way you can I don't
think anybody can out score this office
for the Packers are apparently gonna try
to do with AJ Dillon and a fullback in
the third ran right second question from
Andrew seat in how big of a leap does
drew lock taking year to with all the
talent the Broncos got around him Melo
you get this one first I mean I think
that drew lock could be an MVP candidate
in year two we've seen Pat mahomes win
the MVP in year two we just saw them are
Jackson to it
that's what I know that's what I'm
saying Oh screw me up I think it can be
drool off with the talent that is around
him I don't know if he will win the MVP
but I do think that that could be his
ceiling his for maybe a little bit lower
but I am a big drew lock believer yeah
when you look at it with Drew lock
there's no doubt there should be a big
jump this year I think it goes back to
something Matt said though earlier in
the show I still have concerns about the
offensive line guys and you
I am here to tell you that an offensive
line can wreck a young quarterback
quicker than anything it doesn't matter
who you have it wide receiver running
back so I'm expecting good things for
the Broncos offense this year I'm
expecting good things for Drew lock but
I do think there will be games at times
where that is significantly capped
because of the past protection issues I
hate making this comparison because I
really like Drew lock it feels a little
Baker Mayfield Cleveland Browns year to
where it's like look at all my weapons
and then they would actually you have to
be able to pass looks like right without
the - without you know all the social
media stuff so I do think that yeah the
weapons are fun and the tools are great
they really aren't he has an exceptional
Army's good athlete but that offensive
line is really bad night as Connor said
I mean this is an injured Jets man
speaking from experience with Sam dartle
not you know we see flashes with Sam he
hasn't it'll take the step because of
the line in front of him hopefully drew
lock they get that situated for him as
well all right last question from I
swear to God I had not seen this before
I just spoke last question from John sad
Jets fan excluding quarterbacks who'd
you have as your MVP favorite so no
mahomes no Lamar Jackson no Drew Brees
that's tough I think it's got to be
Christian McCaffrey with what he was
able to do from the running back
position last year I don't have the
notes in front of me I believe he caught
over 100 passes out of the backfield
he's getting a receiver credit he's
getting running back credit and I think
a lot of that offense is gonna go
through Christian McCaffrey this year if
you say no quarterbacks I'm gonna take
the running back who's been very
productive I'll go with the sneaky one I
think Mike Evans can find himself in the
conversation guys when is Tom Brady
thrown to somebody like that in the last
couple years and I know the problem will
be that Chris Godwin is gonna eat
targets you know we'll see what we get
from gronckle always eat some targets
but if I was Tom Brady every time I'm
inside that 20-yard line I'm looking at
Mike Evans there's no reason he can't
catch 15 16 17 18 touchdowns this year
on a winning football team couple of
Bill Polian I said Lamar Jackson's a
wide receiver pick him does that count
I don't think that got a real answer
Michael Thomas got 149 passes last year
and didn't get that type of recognition
I don't know
249 again this year because Emanuel
Sanders and Alva Kumar is healthy but if
we can't pick a quarterback Mike Thomas
is my guy
Nick Bose is my Homer pick though how
deep very very hard you do I think you'd
have to actually break the sack record
Nick Bosa is a sleeper to keep an eye on
there all right that is our show follow
us on twitter at stick to football both
us right here in the BR app as well
don't forget tomorrow Thursday last show
for a little while as we take a summer
vacation but we'll still be active right
here in the collegiate report out and on
Twitter you can follow us at bellow at
Connor Jay Rogers and at NFL Draft Scout
we'll see y'all tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]